The White House has been the residence of
every president since the second, John Adams.
But though it's today the center of national
attention, that hasn't always been the case.
During most of the 19th century, the country
was far more interested in what was happening
in Congress on Capitol Hill than what was
happening here at the White House.
But we live today in a presidential age, so
much so that many Americans think that the
president is in charge of National Affairs.
That's a perception that the political scientist
Hugh Hecle calls "the illusion of presidential
government."
Now, to be sure, the presidency today is far
more powerful than it was in the 19th century.
Government is much larger, and the president
oversees a large number of executive agencies.
As well, the United States is a major player
on the world stage.
That brings the presidency to the forefront.
Yet the reality is, the presidency operates
in a system of divided powers.
The presidency is one branch of the national
government.
The president can propose legislation but
unless Congress goes along, there is no law.
That's the reality of the American system.
Theodore Roosevelt, one of the great 20th
century presidents, said it best.
"I wish, if only for a day, to be Congress
as well as the president.
Then," said Roosevelt, "I'd truly be in charge
of the national government."